excuse me $1,800 Versace today I'm gonna
be reviewing some of the trendiest dad
shoes I am an actual father I have two
sons one is twenty and one is 23 we've
had a lot of experience with shoe
shopping I mean used to pay like twelve
dollars for a pair of lasted a long time
I always thought dad shoes we're
supposed to be super lame I try not to
wear lame shoes I'm very excited
these are actually Kanye's shoes five
one five four a pair of shoes yeah
that's what I'm talking about these are
gorgeous look at the colors orange and
the turquoise and the blue and the
yellow these are amazing for myself I
like pretty out Ricky two shoes it's
pretty freakin hideous to be honest with
you I would wear these right I honestly
I think these are way too cool for Mike
yeah for sure
[Music]
Wow a lot to take in there they have the
soft thing here dads like that
I love them I could see my son's wearing
these they say famous on the side so I
would wear them occur early for that
reason I like the shiny I like to shiny
objects shiny objects make me happy
they're really leading into this dad
thing of just not knowing what the style
is so they just throw all the styles in
together actually you know I'd probably
put the blue shoelace on to $1,800
Versace Wow very nice packaging okay I'm
big on packaging this would make me so
happy to come home holy moly these are
white oh my god these have fur on them
I'd have to go big no on these there's I
feel a little too low to the ground six
inches of white nothingness is just not
enough
oh look in this here this is probably
why it's so expensive because it has
Braille on the sides that probably says
Versace inkay so a person who's blind
falls and grabs you by the foot there
you go
I would love to show up to a barbecue in
these and just not address them all does
not even
talk about it and just have my friend to
be like lose and I would just be like
what are you talking about what are your
shoes these are the heavy ok these what
are these are these supposed to be for
style or for like actually like for
hiking here I can see this like real
leather infused with this material here
that's but breathes you know it has that
breathing kind of material um no no and
they're my children no way I'd have to
pay them is all is this guy's broken
down into areas of your foot which
probably is really comfortable
I don't hate these never mind I do I I
hate the yellow these are it looks like
it's like a face oh it looks like an
animal I see these like in a second-hand
99-cent store a few years it has the
number 43 is it cuz it's like a 43
pounds shoe you just kind of seem the
most dad-ish to me than all the other
ones though which I appreciate it's a
beautiful shoe on that thing it's not
it's a lot of money so close that one up
I'm pretty out there and I'll wear some
interesting stuff but only two of them I
would actually wear which I really like
the other two the early ones but those
last two I'm just not gonna happen
if my kid got me those shoes for a
present I would have the biggest smile
on my face and say you're like the best
kid ever thank you and then as soon as
he started looking up at paw patrol on
the TV I look at my wife and be like I
don't see either of my son's wearing the
Versace but overall I thought the first
two they were reasonably priced probably
involved reasonably priced based on the
high prices of these this footwear that
they're doing today
it was a great experience for these
wonderful shoes I couldn't wear them all
but it was really good thanks goat
Oh
[Music]